why are you purposely not showing Luke
Skywalker in the trailer what is going
on there there's something up there
here's the thing I I really want to make
sure that we're not ruining the movie
for people that are not seeing too much
of it before it comes I just feel like I
hate when I go and see a trailer and I
feel like I've just seen a home movie in
Indiana for making nuts right and yet
that's what sells the movie so it's a
tragedy honey - you don't have to do
that to sell the movie me not to show
the master Star Wars yeah honestly I
don't know for anything I mean I'd
rather be asking questions and feeling
they've been answered for me why is
there a controversy that you cast a
black eye as a stormtrooper you tell me
why couldn't there be a black
stormtrooper I don't understand neither
did I and and understands it's over
there no and I all I know is the john
boyega's extraordinary in the movie yeah
but but but but why are so many people
complaining about this where do I still
troopers come from that they can't be
black I think the people who are
complaining about that probably have
bigger problems then there's a black
stormtrooper